we have a new controversy as we continue
learning more thanks to the january 6th
trump riot committee the new controversy
involves republican congressman barry
loudermilk who is now being accused of
having led a tour
a reconnaissance tour for future
would-be trump rioters before january 6.
now of course he's denying it he says it
was all on the up and up and he gave a
bizarre interview to fox news's laura
ingraham which we're going to look at in
a moment but first let me catch you up
on what it is that is being alleged um
barry loudermilk says that the tour he
gave
was not a reconnaissance tour for future
rioters taking pictures of the security
settings the security situation and uh
tunnels and security cameras but rather
it was um people who just wanted to take
pictures of children's artwork that's
what he says now we'll we'll see if we
believe him newsweek week reporting
representative barry loudermilk said a
group he took through the capitol
complex on january 5th
were simply taking pictures of artwork
and he rejects the insinuation that he
led a reconnaissance tour on the eve of
the insurrection on wednesday yesterday
the january 6 committee wanted an
explanation from him about surveillance
footage showing him taking a group
through the complex with a man seen
photographing security points and
stairwells and the video is pretty weird
the committee has shared footage
purportedly showing the same man who was
taking the pictures
threatening top democrats after the
riots on january 6 by supporters of
ex-president trump some republicans were
accused by democrats of giving tours to
people who later went on to storm the
capitol
while the congressional committee has
requested a meeting with loudermilk u.s
capitol police concluded there is no
evidence he led a tour with trump
supporters trying to learn more about
the complex
on monday capitol police chief tom
manager manger wrote in a letter we do
not consider any of the activities we
observed as suspicious loudermilk told
fox news yesterday the conclusion of the
police doesn't fit the narrative the
january 6 committee wants to come up
with it is a very strange coincidence
that being said
that
supposedly the person he gave a tour to
the day before the riot was then seen
rioting at the capitol that is weird so
let's go to the interview that
loudermilk gave to fox news's laura
ingram
he says they were taking pictures of
children's artwork see if you think he
is telling the truth yeah i mean people
who come to washington dc like these
people who have never been there before
right they're excited
they're taking pictures is it against
protocol or rules to take photos in the
lower level where they were no not
anywhere except for right around the
house chambers that's the only place
that there's no there's no restrictions
in doing this no absolutely not people
take pictures there all the time now in
the video that they show and i know that
if you're listening you won't be able to
see this
it's certainly not evident that the
things that are being photographed are
all you know children's artwork
and also is
is children's artwork that interesting
guys i mean listen i uh
i'm not at the point in fatherhood where
there's any artwork being produced but
i've been around lots of people whose
kids produce artwork
and
it would never really occur to me to
photograph uh kids artwork and also he
initially said that he didn't lead any
tours anyway
uh and then he said that he never heard
from the committee about answering
questions when they actually did contact
him so he has told multiple lies and
it's weird that people who the next day
show up at the riot are that interested
in children's artwork it just doesn't
pass the sniff test for me why doesn't
the january 6 committee show the entire
video because they're taking pictures
all up and down the hallway when the
guys near the tunnels going to the
capitol that's where they hang the
artwork that school children give and at
the other end there is the trolleys the
trains and the kids wanted to see the
trains that take the congressman to the
house chambers that's all this was and
the capitol police they know this all
right so that's his claim
it's weird i mean
something about this doesn't doesn't
really make sense
uh let's go to the next clip sure but
loudermilk has to come and he has to
testify to clear this up do you know
anything about the guy taking the photo
and is is he some nefarious character
not that i know what i mean i did not
know everybody who was in the group as
most members of congress
testify they say uh they haven't asked
me to so that
he says they haven't asked him
the reports are that he has been asked
and so it appears that that's a lie they
keep asking you guys
to have me come they keep releasing this
stuff to the media but they don't send
me the letters okay that as far as we
know that's not true the interview
continues
ringleader in this whole exactly and
what they're not showing is what was the
guy taking a picture of there is a
golden eagle on the wall right upside
that stairwell that's holding two
candles right that's why he's taking a
picture of people take pictures of that
all the time that's all it is except in
all the footage this guy is taking
pictures even when they seem to be going
through security checkpoints and it's
not obvious that there's i mean listen
if an eagle holding candles is that
compelling if
if a kid's art piece of artwork is that
compelling okay but there are videos
where it's not clear that there's any
artwork on the wall
he
wonders why he is being targeted
but what the capitol police said doesn't
fit the narrative that the january 6
committee wants to come up with why
they've targeted me i don't know right
now of course the reason he may be
targeted or the reason that he has
raised eyebrows is he initially said he
didn't lead a tour and then video of him
leading a tour came out and then he's
claiming he hasn't been asked to come
testify except the committee says no we
we did ask him to come and then lastly
he says he will not change his story a
principled and defiant barry loudermilk
he won't change his story because he
must stand for the truth except he's
already changed his story the first
story was i didn't lead a tour now it's
i did but it was all fine guns if
there's pressure i mean come on has
anyone pressured you to to change your
story about this oh absolutely not and i
won't because there is a war on the
truth in this country right now and he's
one of the people who has been caught
lying we have to stand for the truth the
easiest thing for me to do with just
been lay down and go dark i'm not going
to do that we have to stand for truth
and right if we're going to if we're
going to save this country right it
depends the countries
if he
guys i mean we can't
he's been caught lying multiple times
that's why people are focusing on you
okay there were members of congress who
early said oh yeah i led a tour i led a
tour here there here's who showed up
none of the people in the tour later
showed up at the riots this guy denied
leading a tour then the video came out
one of the people who was on the tour
ended up at the capitol on january 6.
he's been caught in multiple lies he's
changing his story already while
simultaneously saying i will not change
my story that's extraordinarily
suspicious so let me know
do you believe him do you i mean it's
it's something is weird about his story
but maybe it rings true to you let me
know what you think
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy is a
totally free service and you'll get five
bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video